[Musique]
j'explique pas mais c'est ça s'est passé
ça c'est ça s'est passé comme ça
[Musique]
chaque
chaque déportés à son histoire
[Musique]
mon père qui vivait en pologne avant
d'arriver en france nous a beaucoup
parlé de la pologne des pogroms qui est
il y avait là bas et nous faisait
remarquer sans arrêt la chance que nous
avions mon frère et moi d'être nés en
france et de vivre d'être français et de
vivre en france nous faisait vraiment
apprécié les valeurs de la république et
toute mon enfance a été bercée comme ça
les parents dit d'un étaient des juifs
immigrés
qui était venu en france pour des
raisons économiques
et que le bic ou de pogroms dans les
pays de l'est qui était quand même un
empêchement de vivre extrêmement fort il
était venu en france pourquoi
parce que la france c'est le pays des
droits de l'homme
c'est le pays auquel on peut faire et on
doit faire confiance la partie de
l'exode c'est à dire en juin 40 moment
où la france est envahie par les
allemands layan un exode immense et
c'est à ce moment là que mes parents
décident de me faire partir à la
campagne
[Musique]
c'est au jeune olivier près de melle à
deux pas du marais poitevin dans ce
bucolique poitou ou l'art de vivre est
une seconde nature qui doit vivre a les
plus belles années de sa vie
alice sa nourrice l'adopter tout amour
la brave femme parvient à atténuer le
chagrin qui oppresse la petite fille
qu'elle est encore lorsque la nuit venue
seule avec elle même elle songe à la
chaleur familiale qui lui manque
beaucoup
comme mû par un étrange pressentiment
l'enfant savourera ces quelques années
de bonheur dont elle parle encore
aujourd'hui des paillettes de ce qu'elle
bleus dans les yeux un bonheur teintait
d'innocence qui tel un miroir se brisera
dans cette maison du bonheur la nuit du
30 janvier 1944
[Musique]
je ne reviens à ma mémoire les souvenirs
familier
je revois ma blouse noire
lorsque j'étais écolier
sur le chemin de l'école le chanter à
pleine voix
des romances sans paroles
vieux chants
d'autrefois
[Musique]
toulouse france
cher pays de mon enfance eux
bercée de tendre insouciant
[Musique]
garder dans mon coeur
tu vas pas me cacher à la campagne parce
qu'il faut quand même savoir que en juin
40 lorsque les allemands rentrent en
france les juifs qui vivent en france
qu'ils soient étrangers ou français
ignorent totalement ce qui va se passer
dont ils ne savent pas que dès octobre
40 il aura le statut des juifs avec
toutes les brimades que ça va entraîner
ont fait avant la guerre ce qui se passe
en allemagne pour les juifs qui sont
chassés exclus qui sont expulsés qui
sont traqués qu'ils sont
tout ça on le sait mais on pense que ça
arrive parce que c'est un régime
fasciste hitlérien mais on pense qu'en
république français ça peut pas arriver
et c'est ça qui est terrible on pouvait
pas imaginer j'ai pourtant il y avait eu
le recensement de 1940 donc les choses
étaient déjà programmés
malgré ça
ils ont été pris de court
ils n'ont pas fait le le passage entre
l'indignité
de ce qu'allait être l'état l'état
vichyste et l'image que eux se faisait
de la france éternelle et là ils ont été
piégés
je serai net de mon père qui me manon ce
que ma mère vienne est arrêté et en fait
ma mère a été arrêtée le 16 juillet 1942
lors de la rafle du 16 juillet c'est à
dire la première fois que l'on arrêtait
des femmes et les enfants
vous savez que des des policiers ont été
consignées dans la cour de la préfecture
de paris on leur a donné des fiches des
listes et on leur a dit que demain matin
il a arrêté des familles femmes et
enfants des familles entières et bien
certains policiers se sont échappés et
sont allés prévenir des familles qu'ils
connaissaient et bien ma merde y'a papa
et ma mère a dit
de femmes et des enfants mais que pour
quoi faire il pouvait concevoir qu'on
apprenait qu'on est arrêtée l'année
d'avant déjà des hommes pour le travail
mais des femmes et des enfants pour quoi
faire et malheureusement ma mère n'y a
pas cru mais elle a eu peur pour mon
père et pour mon frère qui était déjà un
grand jeune homme et elle a absolument
voulu qu'ils aillent se cacher chez des
voisins donc mon père et mon frère ce
cas chez des voisins ma mère s à la
maison elle en a matin l arrêté du 30 au
31 janvier 1944 à minuit passé
trois gendarmes
alors bien sûr ma nourrice elle ne s'est
pas possible n'allait pas arrêter cette
gamine alors là le responsable des trois
gendarmes muret pour nous on a des
ordres ils sont la trouve pas on emmène
votre mari alice elle elle pleurait
toutes toutes ses larmes de son corps la
peau malheureuse elle cette saga lui
tomber dessus comme ça mais moi je vais
pas pleurer parce que je
trouvais que je sais pas quand vous
expliquer pour moi j'avais une sorte de
mépris pour ces gens là me suis dit on
même des français déjà français comment
ils peuvent faire ça et puis j'ai pas
voulu pleurer devant eux par fierté j'ai
pas pleurer l'obéissance
au
garde à vous à tous tout ordre donné
ses commencements de la barbarie il faut
il faut il faut avoir à l'esprit que qui
éventuellement le devoir de
désobéissance face à poser à nous et si
on n'a pas si on n'a pas cette
perspective alors sans nommer de 2,2
d'exécutants il est évident que papon ne
plaît pas plus mauvais homme qu'un autre
mais il ya un moment où il n'y apparaît
pas scandaleux de signer en bas d'un
papier une raie qui sonna gendarmerie
pour aller chercher la juive y d'agrain
cependant son village des deux heures
tant que ça nul à plumes luttons pas de
la main
tout peut s'enclencher les gendarmes par
exemple qu'il pensait pas à mal ils vont
réveiller une gamine de 14 ans au fond
d'une ferme donc à dire que leur voiture
a crevé ou qu' il est ils n'ont pas
trouvé la ferme ni infirmière
l'arrestation des enfants une scène j'ai
là surtout des enfants juifs
c'étaient les samis nation de toute une
race est
programmée dans mein kampf est
programmée dans toute la législation
allemande mise en place dès leur arrivée
en france et dans les autres pays qu'ils
occupaient dans toute l'europe je suis
en belgique c'était pareil bien sûr on
est là tous qui de ce qui pouvait leur
tombait sous la main j'ai même des
enfants de 1 an 2 ans
partez dans les camps de concentration
en arrivant à drancy au secrétariat on
nous dit qu'on va aider porté la semaine
prochaine dans quelques jours on sait
pas exactement quand et on nous dit tout
de suite un pour calmer le jeu pour
partie de révolte pour plus les gens
soient bien disciplinés on nous dit tout
de suite que
ceux qui ont de la famille qui a été
déporté amoureux eh bien on va les
rejoindre
et moi je le crois il ya aucune raison
de ne pas le croire alors dans un sens
ça me remonte le moral ça me réconforte
je dis bon ben je la trouve à man ça
fait un an et demi j'ai pas vu ma mère
et on nous dit qu'on va aller donc
travaillent dans des camps en allemagne
quoi sans donner de plus si on parle pas
de cheese office est absolument inconnu
alors si on ne connaît que l'allemagne
c'est pour ça qu'on dit de drancy
l'antichambre de schwyz drancy était le
point de départ de l'ensemble des
déportés vers auschwitz
les gens qui arrivaient à drancy étaient
soit des gens qui avaient été
préalablement raflé sur paris ou la
région parisienne voire même arrêté dans
la rue ou alors des gens qui avaient
déjà transité dans d'autres camps
notamment les camps du loiret les camps
du sud de la france et qui était la
dernière étape avant d'être âpre et
trans transférés vers vers auschwitz
cette cité qui avait été conçu et que
commencer à être construite dans les
années 1930
comme elle n'était pas achevé qu'elles
n'étaient pas habitées puisqu'il y avait
des problèmes de transport qui se posait
c'était le lieu idéal à l'extérieur de
paris relativement discret pour pouvoir
interne et un grand nombre de personnes
dans la tente d'être déportée par la
suite donc c'est un petit peu par souci
de discrétion est également d'efficacité
entre guillemets qu'on a décidé dans le
début de l'année 1941 de réquisitionner
les bâtiments qui était qui était
inachevée
les départs sauf aisé la première année
c'est à dire de 42 à 43 il se faisait à
la gare dit de drancy qui maintenant
donc et s'appelle la gare du bourget qui
se trouve sur la ligne du rer b et la
deuxième année toujours aussi par souci
de discrétion puisque là il fallait
traverser la ville pour emmener les gens
cette garde du bourget on les fait
partir de l'ancienne gare dit de bobigny
qui se trouve donc sur la nationale en
direction de paris et ceux de 2,43
jusqu'à la libération du camp en temps
[Musique]
c'est une gare de marchandises où on
arrive on arrive sur le quai à bobigny
je sais pas combien il ya la mort c'est
la police française qui ne nous chercher
à drancy où l'un conduit en autobus et
en gare de bobigny le long du pied by un
immense train de wagons à bestiaux keita
qu'est vraiment un très grand train on
trouve je sais pas combien peut-être une
douzaine peut-être plus de ss je sais
pas j'ai pas compté mais c'est que ce
qui est quand même flagrant c'est que
c'est la police française qui nous
emmène sur le quai et qui se retire
après
et après sont les allemands alors
l'embarras l'embarquement se fait à
toute vitesse parce qu'on ne veut pas
attirer l'attention des maisons très
proches de la garde yaga on a interrogé
des gens qui vivaient aux alentours de
drancy à cette époque
qui disait ne savait pas savait pas ce
qui se passait c'est vrai que c'est
difficilement imaginable quand on voit
une cité dans lequel on va jusqu'à
interne et 5000 personnes
avec tous les jours des transferts des
arrivées des départs avec quand même
même si l'alimentation n'est pas
exceptionnel mais quand même
toute une logistique qui est mise en
place avec des camions qui arrivent des
denrées alimentaires et tout ça non les
gens ne savaient pas je savais qu'il y
avait des gens qui te l'a maintenant bon
ça s'arrête là je ne crois pas qu'il
pouvait savoir ce qu'il y avait au bout
du train
mais la capacité de réaction de
quelqu'un qui n'accepte pas
qu'on porte atteinte à l'autre c'est pas
au bout du train c'est avant qu'ils les
montrent c'est avant qu'il soit arrêté
pour qu'on embête et c'est ça le fond du
problème c'est pas de savoir s'ils
savaient où ils allaient
c'est que des gens étaient capables de
savoir que ce n'était pas normal
qu'ils aillent quelque part contre leur
volonté
n'ayant aucune responsabilité aucune
culpabilité sur les chiffres eux qui
sont vraisemblablement les plus les plus
fiables
fonds et tables de près de 80000
personnes qui ont transité par drancy
qu'on était interné à drancy
sur ces 70 7000 exactement personnes qui
sont passées par lan 6 63 me l'ont été
par la suite déportés et 2500 de ses
seuls 63 mille déportés sont revenus
donc la fin de la guerre et je peux vous
assurer que quand on fait le recensement
de tous les actes administratifs
qui ont eu lieu entre les consignes
allemande qui étaient des décors chine
pour initier une demande et la conduite
ensuite de toutes ces consignes au
niveau de l'administration française
tant la préfecture les préfectures les
polices les gendarmeries
on est confondu par l'efficacité
que cette chaîne de responsabilités
obtenu
il faut quand même bien voir que en
france
les allemands qui s'occupait du service
cannes b6 prouesses des 4 b qui avait
charge uniquement de la question juifs
étaient en main un moment final de
l'ordre de 2500
voir des blés compte que s'il n'avait
pas eu cette complicité française
qui aurait jamais eu 76 mille personnes
arrêtées dans les arrestations en france
à partir de 1942 aucun allemand n'est
jamais apparu
depuis les consignes des préfectures des
commissariats et des gendarmeries juges
jusqu'au conduite
des cars qui a amené les gens dans les
centres de rétention
c'est franco français
et la conduite de ces déportés
hommes femmes enfants depuis drancy et
est assuré par qui par la sncf
avec des cheminots français
avec des gardiens gendarmes français et
c'est à la frontière de novaes ans en
moselle que les équipages changé et il
faut s'intéresser aux modes de
financement
que la sncf avait obtenu pour être payés
de ces transports
[Musique]
à
fillon
les conditions du voyage sont tellement
pénible c'est un voyage qui dure trois
jours et trois nuits on est assis bien
sûr on est assis par terre sur le
plancher où on a juste éparpillés un
petit peu de paille il ya une toute
petite lucarne qui laisse entrevoir le
jour lucarne grillagée on est précipitée
en ces vagues on pensait bien que je
voudrais pas j'ai pas compté combien en
était mais on sait maintenant dans les
dents les dans les écrits qui est ce
qu'ils sont là on sait qu'en a fait
voyager les gens de 60 à 70 à 80
personnes dans un wagon
on est très très très très serré dans de
bons lots centre du wagon on a placé un
saut avec de l'eau est un immense bac
est un immense une grande chine est pour
tout le monde
pendant un bon moment personne n'ose
aller à la team est en faisant ça c'est
déjà la première dégradation que nous
avons à subir d'aller faire nos besoins
devant tout le monde mais la voyez tout
de suite la solidarité s'est organisée
parce que des adultes ont attrapé un
manteau par chaque bout et ont essayé de
camoufler les gens qui allaient aux
toilettes et après c'était les autres
gens qui se met enfin bon ben on prend
les trois jours et trois nuits j'ai pas
le souvenir d'avoir eu faim c'est pas ça
qui domine c'est là soit parce que très
peu ton très peu au bout de très peu de
temps l'eau a manqué il y avait juste un
seau d'eau pourtant de tant de personnes
mais la tinette a débordé
l'acide est à déborder parce qu'elle
était pleine à ras bord alors une partie
de son contenu s'est répandu dans la
paille sur le plancher
si fait que nous avons continué le
voyage dans une puanteur absolument
insoutenable
personnellement c'est pour moi le
dirait je souvenir le plus le pigalle et
je ne suis pas la seule parce que
n'importe quel rescapés dit la même
chose et c'est à ce moment là justement
que les gens commencent à parler tout
haut eh puis à dire vivement qu'on
arrive ça fera pas être pire et ça c'est
vraiment le c'est vraiment le leitmotiv
du des derniers moments du voyage si
fait que quand le train s'arrête
brusquement
suisse n'a tous pousser un soupir de
soulagement
d'abord l'arrivée c'est quelque chose
sébastian plus on peut expliquer ce
qu'elle arrive est bon on entend les
convives
ont plombé les portes à glissière sous
le capot on arrive dans un paysage de
neige en quelle campagne on est reçu
entre guillemets par des cris et des
hurlements
ça c'est le comité d'accueil alors
qu'est ce que c'est ce sont les
ssg pure en allemand en chemin elle à
oslo et ce sont leurs chiens elles sont
accrochées au pied et ce sont leurs
chiens policiers qui qui aboie alors
c'est une cacophonie terrible et ça
c'est exprès ou de faire peur
nous a criés rassemblement telles
contraintes lors du suivi des victimes
sont arrivés à la hauteur d'une messe
est ce qu était tout seul et il y avait
toute une oeuvre toute une rangée de
camions qui attendaient derrière les
autres et le ss vous a parlé en français
un mauvais conseils qu'on a très bien
compris nous a dit ceux qui sont
fatigués vous montez en localement ce
qui peut marcher vaut rester là et bien
moi je me suis positionné tout seul avec
les femmes qui marchaient et je me suis
dit oh moi même moi je suis pas fatigué
jamais pourquoi il a fait
alors il se trouve que le ss ne m'a pas
remarqué il était tout seul donc il
était plus affairée que s'il y avait été
il y avait eu quelqu'un avec lui il n'a
pas remarqué a pas fait attention et je
faisais un peu plus que mon âge et il
s'est pas rendu compte mais ne rentrer
dans le camp que les adolescents à
partir de 15 ans et demi de 16 ans qui
pouvaient travailler c'est comme ça que
par miracle on rentrait au fils était un
camp de concentration une petite partie
comme concentration et une grande partie
extermination terry cole fait qu'il y
avait en plus de 80% de juifs donc
c'était camp d'extermination
d'auschwitz ya la sélection dès
l'arrivée c'est la grande différence
avec
le camp de concentration et la sélection
elle ne s'adresse qu'aux juifs
pire que nous fait partie du complexe de
fuite c'est un souk en mai un très grand
souk ans c'est surtout à birkenau que se
trouvent les chambres à gaz et les fours
crématoires donc là le ss quand il a eu
compté et recompté le nombre de femmes
que lui avaient l'ordre de faire rentrer
ce jour là dans le camp ils nous
escorter à dire que nous j'étais dans le
même transport qui d'agrain ce pan on
est arrivé à schwyz l'a en descendant de
wagons il ya un allemand clm des quel
âge as-tu jeudi j'avais 23 ans être en
bonne santé je dis oui oui et puis je
parle l'allemand je suis né en allemand
tu veux travailler je dis je suis venu
pour travailler
je ne savais pas que c'est un camp
d'extermination
ça fait qu'il a choisi soixante et une
personnes dont idaho si nous nous
connaissions pas au début est depuis des
hommes à côté puis tout le reste son
parti
un four crématoire de gazage on nous a
rentré enfin tout ça avec des grands
émotions des larmes je pleurais mon
enfant mon enfant
et un jour on m'a dit si tu pleures tu
sortiras pas d'eux ici faut que tu
arrêtes de pensée de ta vie intérieure
pense à avancer maintenant temps que tu
peux nous avons été au dessin d
habillage à la douche rasé tatoué on
nous a donné des habits
les chaussures on se laissait plus
recherchés parce qu'on n'avait pas tous
les mêmes grandeur de pied quand il
fallait avoir des chaussures adaptées à
votre pied
difficile enfin des habits qu'ils
n'étaient pas des habits chauds
n'importe quoi on nous a bus ni
n'importe quoi et nous sommes rentrés
dans le camp première impression que
j'ai eue de ce
qu on appelle ça des couilles à des
espèces de casiers où on s'en fout rne
nous on nous en a mis six parcs haussier
quand il a fallu dormir ici s'il a fallu
qu'on se tourne tous en même temps et on
a changé tous les jours nous avons
changé que ce qu est un extrémités sont
venus au milieu afin que nous puissions
avoir chaud aux 8 de temps en temps
parce que celle qui est un extrémité
n'était pas bien couvercle il faisait
vraiment très très froid tout de suite
immédiatement on a instauré un tour de
rôle et chacune autour dormait au milieu
et puis je sais que d'autres camarades
d'autres d'autres groupes l'ont fait
aussi si on n'avait pas fait ça qu'est
ce qui se serait passé les plus faibles
elle aurait toujours été découverte
dans ces conditions nous nous trouvions
le monde le monde se transforme il ya
des gens qui peuvent rester bien moi
j'ai toujours dit qu'une fois qu'on nous
a enlevé nos habits nos cheveux nobi
chute continue quand même vers
le vernis tombe aussi on le devient
on est vrai ont des frais périodiquement
il ya des sélections
dont quand à n'importe quel moment les
médecins jeudi toujours à les appeler
médecin c'est ces gens là enfin les
médecins ss arrive nous font déshabiller
complètement nu et les chaussures aussi
parce qu'ils veulent voir l'état des
pieds et puis vous passez devant les ss
et ils vous regardent dans tous les sens
et c'est eux qui juge si oui ou non vous
êtes encore aptes au travail alors nous
on se re nous on a un réflexe on se
tient droite on bombe le torse on l'a
surtout de trouver un truc hein on fait
comme ça on se pince comme ça très fort
les joues pendant un peu de couleurs
parce qu'on est complètement blanche
mais on a des réflexes de survie comme
ça et puis on passe et puis ce sont les
ss qui alors selon ce qu'ils décident
ils vous il relève votre numéro qui sur
le bras il heureux il leur plaît tenue
il le relève sur une liste et on vient
vous chercher après dans le blog et on
vous emmène dans un blog spécial que le
bloc 25 qu'il a je sais pas combien de
temps reste les les femmes puisque j'ai
eu la chance de ne pas être dans ce blog
je veux dire je crois que c'était une
journée où les frais un peu plus et ça
c'est vraiment le maximum de l'horreur
parce que elles sont dans cette pièce et
elles savent qu'elles vont passer à la
chambre à gaz
nous étions donc 45 femmes
contre aille rapidement on a attrapé
beaucoup ont attrapé le typhus il y
avait des poux bien grasset on a eu les
poux
la malchance de certaines a été de se
gratter
d'être piqués par l'époux et de ce grade
dit se faire des croûtes
et quand les sélections sont venues
toutes celles qui avaient des croûtes
sont partis à la chambre à gaz
fait au bout de moi nous n'étions que
sept sur les 45
et au bout de quatre mois on était trois
mois j'appréhende et les dimanches parce
que je me souvenais qu'on avait chanté
pendant avant le début de la guerre est
une chanson qui s'appelait sombre
dimanche
et qui dit jean se suicider non se
suicider pas me tuer lorsque je suis
arrivé au camp d'auschwitz
je me suis dit tiens on ne me tue pas
moi je savais ce qui se passait j'avais
vu une photo horrible j'avais vu une
photo un rib dedans dans le cadre du
mouvement de résistance auxquels était
une faute horrible ce qui avait eu lieu
dans le côté du ghetto de varsovie est
prise à varsovie c'est 2
2 cavaliers et c'est sous enfin elles
n'ont qui avait pris un gamin
un jeune garçon et qu'il avait pris avec
des cordes et qu'il est qui le déchirent
et en deux
quand vous voyez des choses comme ça vu
que j'avais entendu là le bon la radio
anglaise que j'avais un certain nombre
de l'information
j'appartenais à ce qui était peut-être
les
moins crédules
alors sur le coup c'était ça mais le
coût du gazage quand j'ai vu senti
g vous savez nous sommes 60 ans après
j'ai encore j'ai encore de la peine à
imaginer tech que cette réalité elle
existait le 18 janvier on évacue
les virus arrive l'iap les allemands
reçoivent l'ordre de nous évacuer oncle
et bagages et on fait cette route
terrible
qui va durer trois jours dans la neige
sans nourriture sans rien
sans qu on la paie la marque de la mort
parce que environ la moitié des gens
sont tombés dans la route particulier s
s achever les gens qui marchent et
celles qui doivent avancer les morts
étaient fichés debout assis pas debout
mais assis raide
gelé parce que c'était mois de janvier
il faisait un froid
très terrible terrible
survécu comme ont servi dans des
conditions comme ça on sépare c'est pas
pourquoi on a cette force parce que on
était quand même pas dans les meilleures
formes pour subir un voyage pareil
pendant qu'on marchait quand on avait
une fille qui était fatigué qui était au
bord on la prenait vite au milieu pour
pas qu'ils soient remarqués par les 16es
on lui donnait le bras pour qu'elle
marche il ya des moments où on m'a donné
le braille est des moments où moi je
année le bras alors je crois que sans
l'aide des camarades je sais pas ce que
je pense que personne n'aurait pu faire
la marche c'était assez des petites
chaînes de solidarité sans arrêt après
on nous a mis dans des wagons
ouvert
bestiaux là on a fait encore trois jours
je crois en été gelés contre ces wagons
je ne sais pas comment on est sortis de
là et nous avons terminé notre temps
prisonnière
à neuf dates alors là c'était un camp de
mouroir on n'avait plus de on avait plus
de chambres à gaz les chameaux rennes
naturellement d'épuisement
et là à 9,4 ida était vraiment dans un
état lamentable lamentable
c'est à dire que déjà elle l avait de la
fièvre elle avait ses pieds qui étaient
gelés
elle commencé à délirer
et nous étions à ce moment là dans une
nous avons été rassemblés en arrivant ne
jeta dans une baraque où il y avait que
de la paille et on était mal nourris
parce que c'était c'était nous étions
beaucoup trop nombreux c'était un camp
qui était complètement désorganisée et
quand j'ai vu ça quand j'ai vu ça je me
suis dit me 7,7 vous savez c'était ma
soeur de misère elle était plus petit
que moi c'était la petite j'avais quitté
mon mes deux frères et si vous voulez
j'avais pour elle
un amour fraternel
ça n'a pas de mot donc cette petite
soeur de misère qu'ils allaient si on ne
faisait rien allez avoir avait déjà les
pieds gelés bon quand la grangrène
cimail bon c'est bien ce qu'il en
résulte et j'ai pris mon courage à deux
mains parce que je ne parlais pas
l'allemand
parce qu'il faut des cups à plusieurs
reprises le yiddish de ida m'a bien aidé
parce que quand on appelait mon numéro
elle me disait toujours si toi c'est toi
qu'on appelle ou alors elle me disait
bestway brestois elle vous savez c'était
s'est elle m'a beaucoup aidé donc si
vous voulez j'étais très me suis très
attaché à elle et quand on était au même
stade j'ai dit faut la sauver il faut
faire quelque chose alors la première
fois j'ai dit tu sais qu'on va
s'échapper on va s'échapper et on va
essayer que tu rentres aurait vivre le
rêve vire bombe et c'était bon le la
baraque de l'infirmerie quoi la chance a
voulu que la porte s'ouvre et que j'ai
pu la projeter dans les bras d'une dame
bon qu'est devenu son infirmière et qui
lui a sauvé la vie où je peux dire que
j'ai survécu grâce à elle
ainsi wanda c'était son nom sauve aïda
d'une mort certaine au lendemain de ce
jour de liesse le plus beau le plus
joyeux qu'ait connu le monde libre
d'hier à churchill ida recherchera sans
désemparer sa bienfaitrice lorsqu'enfin
en 2001 elle l'a retrouvera wanda dans
le coma mourra avant qu'il ait pu lui
dire merci
le débarquement sonne le glas des
troisièmes rech bientôt les malheureux
déportés seront libérés
l'immonde boîte nazis et vaincre tous
les déportés qui sont revenus en gamme
moment donné une chance c'est pas des
grosses et des petites chances les unes
après les autres
demandez aux rescapés d'auschwitz la
confiance qu'il faisait à l'homme
l'homme avec un grand h quand ils sont
sortis de leur camp
demandez-leur dont l'idée qu'ils se sont
fait de la notion de dieu dans des lieux
des extrêmes comme les camps de
concentration extermination
moi je peux pas répondre j'aime pas le
droit de répondre je sais que cette
notion
était nulle et négatives
pourquoi parce qu'
une des raisons
qui ont fait que les allemands ont créé
ces camps s'étaient qui voulait rendre
l'homme un loup pour l'homme
et que dans leur déstructuration de
l'aisne de ce qu'un homme dans son
humanité
ils ont détruit aussi cela pour qu'il
devienne une bête par rapport à son
frère
d'aucuns avec moi même on dit dieu
n'était pas archi très clair
il était petit mais n'a pas empêché
qu'il ya une fraternité entre les hommes
trop certains
il n'y a pas empêchés et qu'il y ait une
aide entre certains hommes il n'y a pas
non plus
empêcher que
la loi de la jungle existe lorsqu'on se
trouve dans une jungle et où nous nous
trouvons dans des phénomènes de survie
c'est une chose terrible
de détruire en l'homme sa capacité
d'attention à l'autre
parce qu'il est uniquement dans une
condition de survie élémentaire
on a vu des pères qui m'ont - qui ont
empêché leurs enfants leur fils de
manger on a eu on a des choses qui sont
absolument épouvantable c'était une
politique délibérée
ce qui est plus choquant c'est de voir
qu'on voulait vraiment nous avilir vous
enlevez tout nous réduire comme des
bêtes on nous enlever toute notre
dignité et je crois que pour
que c'était une grande brèche lutter
pour rester digne c'est une forme de
résistance qui a une personne dans ma
vie
dont j'ai employé un mot dans mon
chrétien mais dont on sait qu'elle était
une sainte c'est ma mère qui a eu aucune
attitude admirable qui se serait
vraiment laisser tuer on ressasse hop et
autres non pas par faiblesse mais parce
que tu es si on apprend c'est qu'il en a
plus besoin que moi enfin c'était
et
elle était tout à fait dans la vie
toujours c'était vraiment le portait sur
son visage d'ailleurs cette volonté
cette confiance en l'homme dans les
gendres et
elle n'avait aucune foi religieuse
n'en avais pas eu besoin elle était
telle qu'elle était c'est d'ailleurs
particulièrement intéressant de
devoir dans les périodes de survie
comment des hommes qui sont
peut-être moins instruits que d'autres
mais ont des grandeurs d'hommes
extraordinaire des qualités
insoupçonnées alors peut-être qu'il va
les rechercher dans la religion
peut-être qu'ils vont aller rechercher
dans la danse qu'ils ont appris dans le
civisme ou dans ce qui a été leur
culture personnelle ou familiale mais
j'ai vu des choses tellement immense de
gens peu instruits de gens peu instruits
mais tellement énorme est ayant
tellement de qualités humaines quand on
pense que tout était programmé moi ce
qui me paraît pas comprendre c'est qu'on
a lancé des appels d'offres pour
construire un complexe chambres à gaz
comme atouar donc ce sont des jeunes des
architectes qui ont fait ça et on a pris
le plus rentable le moins cher ils
faisaient qui contenait le plus en mai
c'est impensable quand même que des gens
aient pu construire des choses comme ça
c'est pareil que le laboratoire qui a
donné le site lombez des tonnes et des
tonnes de sic l'ombella leuze ce cristo
est parti dans les camps s'étaient
pouvez quand même se poser la question
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça alors tout
ça c'était motus et tous bu tout était
d'abord c'était tout était organisé
c'est l'organisation scientifique qui
fait frémir c'est que l'alm les
allemands qui sont un peuple intelligent
cultivé et tous ont mis leur
intelligence au service de la mort
pourquoi détruire un homme qui est votre
égal
sans parler d'être votre frère qui est
une autre notion de relation
mais un homme
qu'ils soient juifs
noirs jaunes
communiste
c'est un homme
nul n'a le droit d'empêcher un homme de
vivre
et la perversion absolue
que le nazisme a eu envers un groupe
humain qui était devenu son ennemi
singulier a été de mettre en oeuvre
cette politique d'extermination
volontaire d'un groupe humain qui
n'avait pas fait autre chose que d'être
né ce qu'il était
les enfants qui sont partis
et j'ai des photos d'enfants ici
ils vous regardent à travers une photo
ces enfants seraient aujourd'hui des
hommes de nos âges
itil pardonnable
que pour la seule raison
il était né d'une mère juive ou d'une
famille juive qu'ils aient été mis à
l'abattoir c'est pas acceptable
d'une manière absolue quand je pense au
camp et à tout ce qui s'est passé à ce
que j'ai vécu mais surtout à ce que j'ai
vu c'est la chose qu'encore aujourd'hui
je ne supporte pas même d'y penser je ne
le supporte pas quand je pense à la rand
de birkenau arriver les trains et on les
voyait arriver de nos baraques et qu'on
voyait qu'il y avait des enfants et
concise avec tous ses enfants
une demi-heure après ne vivrait pas
c'est une l'idée même est insupportable
je me souviens matins comme ça avoir été
travaillé près du
magasin crématoire à creuser des fossés
il devait y avoir des problèmes de
canalisations vont creuser on était dans
une équipe de terrassement et y avait
encore il y avait un train ou plusieurs
trains qui étaient peut-être arrivé dans
la nuit et en les gens en occident
déshabiller il y avait sur une
pelouse la veille d'ailleurs oui alors
tout est pensé comme une c'était souvent
il y avait des fleurs il y avait des
vêtements d'enfants des jouets des
béquilles aussi une puisse être des
stars à izieu dont je m'occupe ont
[Musique]
le plus le plus poignant ces cantons on
récite la liste des 44 enfants en
donnant leur âge c'était il y en avait
eu un certain nombre qui n'avaient pas
six ans
83e 3 aïn bessam
sait plus comment un père de famille car
ils étaient tous que ce soit les
musiciens ou les nazis peu pouvaient
pouvait exécuter cet ordre là sauf
admettent que il ya le si on fait passer
le drapeau la nation et lors du chef
avant
7,7 el kaabi l'habitude si mais c'est
elle et quand vous et on vous avez
rempli un convoi de deux mille personnes
ben déjà le millier suivant vous poser
les bonnes questions je suppose je
suppose j'ai jamais eu la mauvaise idée
la mauvaise qualité de matériaux g sur
ce qui se passait dans leur tête mais le
brave père de famille falguera haut qui
poussait avec son ex que ton des enfants
dans les dents les dans les
wagons sachant ce qui les attendait ils
le savaient mieux personnes ça reste un
geste il inouïe et plus il enfin à ben
on est abasourdi moi j'en ai
j'ai reçu après l'aller après la fin de
la guerre j'ai géré aussi une dans les
180 enfants on m'avait confié pour les
remettre en état pendant trois mois dans
une colonie de vacances pour les
remettre dans le circuit normal de la
vie avec des adultes donc j'avais une
petite fille kb peut-être n'ont-ils
trois ans qui ne
qui ne savaient qu'ils ne savaient pas
marché qui ne savaient pas manger
puisque pour manger on lui tient
pourtant pas par terre elle l'a ramassé
avec sa bouche
mais il a fallu tout lui apprendre et
lui apprendre ap à s'asseoir sur une
chaise lui apprendre à se tenir sur une
table rim table lui apprendre à manger
et lui apprendre à parler et voilà même
en trois mois on lui a même appris à
chanter et à sourire donc c'était le la
plus belle la plus belle des victoires
d'arriver à sortir ses enfants en bas
âge de la nuit de la terreur ce que je
voudrais dénoncer
c'est le crime de l'homme contre l'homme
d'abord et puis ensuite que l'on puisse
se souvenir d'une manière extrêmement
claire que si cela a eu lieu c'est grâce
à une administration
qui 2 a à z a été complice et active
c'est pas du tout une opération
passionnel
c'est pas un crime parce que tu me plaît
pas je te tue
c'est un crime parce que tu es ce que tu
es et tu ne me plaît pas toi et les
tiens je veux te détruire et pour ça je
crée tout à toute une hiérarchie
administrative dont on a parlé un peu et
ça je crois que c'est cette notion
de rationalisation du crime absolu qui a
été possible
et qu'il faut tout faire pour ne pas
revoir
se pointer à l'horizon je dirais
naturellement de ne pas oublier d'abord
par respect pour tous ceux qui sont
morts pour l'histoire pour qu on sache
ne serait ce que pour ça qu'on sache
sans même penser à des leçons en tirer
il faut le savoir six millions de morts
il faut vraiment qu'on n'oublie jamais
au sortir de la guerre
nous avions tellement vu des choses
horribles que pendant des années des
années on n'a pas eu la possibilité
on n'avait pas le la vente et on n'avait
plus la volonté d'ouvrir la bouche et
dire ce qu'on avait vécu d'horreur
c'était en fait rami en nous mêmes et ça
ne pouvait pas sortir c'était pas
possible au fur et à mesure que passent
les décennies nos camarades
disparaissent puisque maintenant moi
j'ai 82 ans les camarades disparaissent
chaque année on est de moins en moins
nombreux et je crois que moins nous
devenons nombreux et maintenant plus ne
devons parler
pour les anciens déportés que mme ida
salon est une obsession
il faut il faut témoigner à tout prix
pour que tous nos voisins de barack ne
soient pas morts pour rien c'est à je
suis pas mécontente que mon nom
soit associé à ça ce témoignage qui est
exemplaire de beaucoup d'autres parce
que c'est une traversée de l'horreur qui
qui a été partagé par beaucoup donc
conçu fait c'est pas dire que je m'en
suis fait un devoir ça s'est imposée à
moi comme une des causes qui elle était
sûre parce que j'ai l'âge d'avoir
côtoyé des causes politiques mais qui
méritait tout qu'on ne fait pas toujours
qu'on se dévouent pour elle tandis celle
là elle est d'une pureté diamants je
veux dire la la la déportation d'un
enfant
le jour où l'humanité ne sera plus
abasourdi par cette par ce scandale ce
sera très grave
oubliez ça serait une capitulation
c'est une capitulation de l'esprit
une capitulation de l'homme
et je crois que ça serait une défiance
de ce qui fait qu'un homme est un homme
moi je le perçois plus comme une
responsabilité vis-à-vis des vivants
d'aujourd'hui et des générations de
demain la crainte qu'on peut
effectivement avoir c'est que lorsque
les derniers survivants les derniers
témoins de cette époque ont disparu on
rentre dans l'histoire bon et c'est vrai
que on étudiera la shoah comme on étudie
le moyen âge comment étudier la guerre
de cent ans ce sera consigné dans des
manuels d'histoire bon il n'y aura pas
de réflexion puisque ça fera partie
d'une époque
qui n'est plus la nôtre bon d'où
l'intérêt quand même bon quelques années
j'espère qu'ils seront le plus longue
possible on a encore des témoins d'où
l'intérêt de recueillir au maximum ces
témoignages et après
ça n'aura pas la même consistance mais
d'essayer quand même de les faire passer
auprès des auprès des jeunes générations
encore une fois en leur disant attendez
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui s'est
déroulée au moyen âge c'est pas quelque
chose qui s'est déroulé à telle époque
c'est là c'est récent c'était au siècle
précédent
on a un instinct de vie quand on est
très jeune à mon avis on a un instinct
de vie plus développé qu'une personne de
35 40 ans
il ya une petite
phrase tout petit une toute petite
petite part d'inconscience parce que les
faits sont là y'a la cheminée qui brûle
on sait que tu vois on a journellement
n'allait capot qu'il ne démolisse le
moral jor-el mandat les capots qui nous
insultent et qu'il nous dise n'importe
comment ils s'y rendent par la porte on
sort pas la cheminée sein c'est le
leitmotiv tu vois les capots et malgré
tout on se cramponne on se dit faut
tenir le coup ci a passé si on n'a pas
une sélection faut tenir le coup faut
qu'on s'en sorte
c'est certainement une réelle d'espérer
mais on a quand même dit une petite
lueur
puis à des moments où on perd l'espoir
aussi les camarades qui vous remonte le
moral et vice versa
on n'a plus d'espoir comptable soit on a
plus de forces on ne tient que par la
volonté alors quand on appuie cette
volonté de vivre on n'a plus la volonté
de se battre pour trouver un peu d'eau
pour se laver
c'est fini on on croule quoi on se
laisse aller
oui à la libération j'ai envoyé un
télégramme et elle a couru les lui à
paris que jusqu'à la fin de ma nourrice
elle était très croyante très catholique
très croyante mais c'était quand elle
évoquait et quentin moquer de lui
c'était toujours la sainte vierge pas
dieu alors la fin une promesse que si je
revenais elle ferait une offrande à la
chapelle et à la tenue parole comme je
suis revenu elle a offert une belle ça
se fait à la chapelle et qu elle était
pas très riche et ce qu'elle a fait de
bien c'est que pour le cas où la
statuette elle se casse aussi qu'il
s'attend en plâtre au mur ils ont
excellé une plaque merci à marie 1945
et 50 et m'a montré ce après la guerre
j'étais très bouleversée c'était
vraiment très touchant
[Applaudissements]
la douleur au pied droit avec avec ses
petites exigences les élèves demandent
alors n'importe quoi qui vous arrive
alors maintenant madame à côté du tout
ce que vous avez vécu ma vie dit non
c'est pas vrai parce que justement on
reprend on
reprend le goût de la vie et les choses
elles ont aussi leur petite importance
et c'est ça qui est bien ça serait je
crois épouvantable sûr si j'étais blonde
et 2010 au passage à part importante du
mobile non non non
[Musique]
mais pas reçu de l'éducation religieuse
je pouvais pas me mettre à prier quand
j'étais au camp mais dans ma petite haie
je disais quand même notre dieu le dieu
des juifs il nous laisse et nous laisse
franchement tomber voilà ce que j'ai eu
comme réaction et au fond de moi je suis
sincère vous faudra vu dix ans mais
n'importe comment alice quel prix pour
moi
[Musique]
lorsque les nazis va chercher les
communistes je me suis tu je n'étais pas
communiste
lorsqu'ils ont enfermé les
sociaux-démocrates je me suis tu je
n'étais pas social démocrate
lorsqu'ils sont venus chercher les juifs
je me suis tu je n'étais pas juif
quand ils sont venus chercher les
catholiques je me suis tu je n'étais pas
catholique et quand ils sont venus me
chercher
il n'y avait plus personne pour
protester
[Musique]